obj really should be a Pitch man yeah
what's he doing he's one of the most
well-adjusted people I've seen
I mean to be honest I mean it's crazy
yeah he's one of the most like if you
see him on Twitter like of course he
makes good points he's always like happy
smile on his face relax and because I
think he did what he he wanted to do
like yeah he was like how many people
could kill someone who's bothering them
get away get away with it and then on
the other side be like okay yeah I mean
that's got look morality aside it's got
to feel awesome to get away with and not
just not even just like he planned it
out he was studying for years it was
like he did it it was so clear he did it
was supposed to be done everyone knew he
murdered it he probably saw her and him
[__] through the window and went
tonight didn't he kill like her gay
friend not the guy she [__] no Ron
Goldman was the guy she was [__] and
he I think one of the theories is that
he saw them through the window right
right and was like it's on and then he
went in there and you know cut their
heads
that that being said I've never seen a
person on social media that I I feel is
in a better place yeah he's happy and
look he's amazing if you kill someone
and you get away with it so publicly
it's like unless we're forgetting the
man is a Hall of Fame running back the
man is
that people will never be he's an actor
that's his third running back he's been
in he's been in uh he was he was almost
gonna be the Terminator oh he was a
finalist for the Terminator before
Schwarzenegger got it he's in all the uh
uh the Naked Gun movies I might have to
put him forth in my most American lives
I have uh the my the people that have
lived lives that could really only be
possible in America and my my top three
it's in the water but it's Donald Trump
yeah Caitlyn Jenner right and Alex Jones
and I might have to put O.J Simpson as
fourth in terms of like lives that are
really only possible in America for my
money dude he might be right under DT he
might be because I agree with you
because yeah oh I mean just truly a star
and a USC we haven't even thought about
all the [__] he got oh you know I mean
he killed it he's got it literally but
he's and now now he's just in Vegas
having a good time nobody he's become
this like and I think if people see him
out now like I gotta be honest with you
I'm over it I think a lot of people are
over it I think a lot of to be honest I
mean I know what you're saying you know
what I mean at the same time there's
levels to that statement because you're
you know having a life we're having a
nice little time here but at the same
time
I see him on I see him online and I
don't think there's a murderer I don't I
don't have any anger towards him I think
listen OJ's got a towards that man if I
saw him in Vegas
I would be excited I would kind of be
really excited I'd be like hey OJ like
hey can I get a photo I'm a really big
fan no legit just for the Instagram
I mean how many people are doing that by
the way everybody's probably doing that
100 and imagine him thinking like when
he's standing there you know in court
and all this horrible stuff's coming out
I wonder if he thought like hey man this
is all gonna shake out yeah one day
Donald Trump will be the President right
right Bruce Jenner will transition to
Caitlyn and then I'm gonna be in Vegas
and people are going to be actually
coming up to me going hey I'm a big fan
the nelk boys had them on the podcast
he's kind of rehabilitated he's kind of
rehabilitated I would literally go up to
O.J Simpson and go I am a huge fan and I
would love a photo
I would guess and I'm very confident he
decapitated his wife and her lover but I
would I would absolutely go up to him
and go I am a huge big fan massive fan
of yours
can I get a photo and then I would put
it on my Instagram and try to come up
with a funny caption and I think you
figure it out that's how over it I am of
course I'm kind of over it I wouldn't do
that with Dylan roof sure I wouldn't do
that with someone I think is like I
think Dylan roof is evil yeah and
because I think he win any targeted
People based on their race 100 and I
think that's that there's something
inherently evil about a person who walks
into a church yeah but a house in
Brentwood where you're second off a
waiter and a church that ain't a church
and there's just different it's not a
church and I'm I'm not saying it's right
I'm not right but is it impossible
worship no yeah here's another fun yeah
if you really want to spin and you
really want to start getting crazy with
it being pro OJ
the reason he what's one of the biggest
signs of CTE is damage is brain damage
it's aggression it's violence so not
only that you could make him like like
by the way the NFL when O.J Simpson dies
will drop a nuclear bomb on the funeral
home that he's in so that science
doesn't get a hold of his brain right
because it like truly he got he went
crazy because he was one of the best I
mean dude that [__] was playing
when they had like one Strat one helmet
right you know I mean they had like one
little thing was getting hit and taking
heads all the time yeah he's a gladiator
for your enjoyment in many ways if you
love the NFL you killed Nicole Brown
Simpson and a lot of people are okay
with that if you put it in those terms
a lot of people are okay with that I
gotta be honest because number one
people hate LA right they hate laws
there's never been a city that has hated
more kind of justifiably than La no one
cares
a woman now this might be wrong this is
probably wrong but a woman who's seen as
a gold digger
is not going to get the same level of
sympathy as the juice then as it as The
Talented uh man who's made the money I'm
not hey did I make the world am I God
I'm reporting what happens if anything
this is a news show this is a I'm a
media figure and I'm reporting the news
litigating the O.J Simpson murders I
gotta be a gas digital Studio I gotta be
honest with you there's not a man I'd be
more excited to see in Las Vegas
there's no could you think of a person
in Las Vegas you'd be happier to see
than OJ [__] Simpson no not I mean I
guess carrotop Christmas I would ask him
for weight loss advice
I would I would hold myself accountable
I may text OJ my steps every now
that's how much I respect you want an
ongoing relationship I love the naked
guns so like there's a there's a version
of me that's at the end of every night
going OJ I only got 7 500 in today
because I'm on the road he's like don't
worry about it brother try to hit 12
tomorrow we all make mistakes try to hit
12 000 tomorrow he's like keep the carbs
you know after 3 P.M no carbs yeah yeah
yeah I
let's let me also just throw this out
please and this might not
is he the worst father probably not
he's probably not the worst dad in the
world he's probably a pretty good dad
and he probably compensates for the
incident he had right right right by
being a better father I think this is
the first place you're kind of starting
to lose me really I think murdering your
mother
really puts you I would say I don't
think it's ideal
[Music]
but I'm wondering do do his kids still
have her that's a great question I think
that you could could someone here look
at it one of The Producers see against
digital what you have to do is walk out
with a loaded gun it's this is not the
Jamie Vernon experience you have to walk
out you have to put a gun in there
um we kid we kid but
um I think they actually established I
think they do interesting I think they
have a pretty good relationship with
them because I did hear one theory that
was uh that the sun didn't the sun did
my mother was obsessed
[Music]
I was in a Comedy Central sketch about
O.J Simpson what I'd like the producers
to do right is if they can I would like
them to get up just say no J and this
may be the first time it is but OJ was a
big part of my life yeah
um this was the massive trial we watched
the verdict in fifth grade and we turned
it on in our school there was a sketch
called just say no J it was released uh
on Comedy Central it was one of these
sketches that they would put between
shows and I played a kid who's playing
with the DNA testing kit my father in
the sketch was playing with a Bronco and
my mother was doing Marcia Clark's
cookbook uh who was the prosecutor in
the case and the idea was that the O.J
Simpson trial had invaded the home of
every American Family to an unhealthy
degree at comedy Central's marketing
campaign was just say no Jay stop
watching the trial start watching uh
what we're doing start watching uh
reruns of Saturday Night Live yeah and
Mystery Science Theater and whatever
right and premium blend do we have this
let's watch just saying I would love to
Let's watch this so this is you as a
child this is the first time this has
been played on my podcast I think
oh
hey that's my boy
crushed it I've been in this business
for years
oh was it after that point that he told
you he'd take the next flight yes
from Comedy Central wow so
congratulations man thank you but that's
gas digital the grotesque gas schedule
[Laughter]
um but that is where I you know this is
how big the O.J Simpson tutorial was in
the 90s is hard to explain to these
youngins now your mother when she was
she was obsessed with the son did it
Theory yeah she in an institution at the
time or she no my mother only went in
when I was in my 20s okay all right so
she like what happens with schizophrenia
it either comes on hard in the 20s or
it's usually kind of later in life
hormonal menopause in the 40s midlife
crisis 40s things like that more common
in women than men still happens in men
um but usually it comes on early yeah
but there are cases where I think hurt
the hormonal thing I think that's a lot
along covet not that it's schizophrenia
but it's menopausal right right a lot of
it's hormonal yeah um so The OJ's so
that was one of my first gigs one of my
first things I ever did and we went to
this house in Connecticut and my
grandmother went with me and it was just
like an all-day shoot but it was cool
yeah and it was like oh I'm in this I'm
in this thing now yeah wow so yeah J OJ
one of your first paying jobs it
wouldn't happen without him one of my
first paying gigs so like I'm in the
business
because of the Jews
hahaha